col baffe dei ragazzi era da un bel
pezzo che lo faceva un player non oggi
ci sono sia pietro che thomas visto che
non sono mai di scegliere tra i due
perché uno è gay
l'altro dall'altro è un fagiano vi
spiego siano giocavamo per i fattacci
nostri io quando giochiamo per i fatti
nostri ogni tanto registro e ho fatto
mash up delle cose divertenti che sono
successe durante questi queste sessioni
di videoludiche notturne accalappia
patata perché arriva un sacco di gnocca
quando giochiamo e videogiochi
ve lo assicuro vi ricordo che come
sempre l'obiettivo è arrivare tra i
primi 100 giocatori bisogna arrivare
primi cosa che non succede mai però
vabbè buona visione
ho trovato una macchina forse riesco a
prenderla si va dalla panchina trovato
una quadra una qualunque ma l'ho trovato
un buggy o poi vestiti tutti
ecco uno li investo credo non lo so ci
prova ci provo
no mi sono scagliato un appropriato 11
ed ha investito quello che ha toccato
l'onore
ciao immesso tour di non investire bene
cosa avevo viste le cose sono accadute
cos'è successo va bene madonna ha vinto
la sorella ce la farò una intanto vive
mi dispiace neanche quello neanche
quello aiuto aiuto io non si prova tutto
va bene macro capisco
oggi non ci sono un numero nella zona
tir il successivo caso fruttano benefit
animando un peso per ora vai di pugni ma
di pugni la moglie la guardia non ci
sono più
ci sono 1 col banking
ha colpito due volte ma motto è morto
non è morto e non è morto un altro ok
non campionissimo arriva un altro sempre
dietro o mio dio nuova promessa da
questa bellissima e stato stupendo è una
cosa bellissima
se non ci fossero non ho mai visto
cappottarsi così male scusate scusa
scusa scusa scrivendo tra visite da
finta cazzo state facendo
vi fa schifo fate vivere da lontano col
mirino e sparare tutte e due
e cosa basta e monardi per che bella
privacy
glielo devo portarla sul treno quando
devo pagare e muoversi a proprio nome ed
io ho un mio avviso siamo arrivati per
te perfetto perfetto parcheggio perfetto
bravo e hp tutto calcolato certo ogni
istante di questa cosa è stata calcolata
la thomas altra macchina a norma che c'è
mafia iorio
ma che cosa vengo io lo sapevo mi hanno
fumato la faccia di una casa facevano in
caso siano sono un deficiente pensavo
che purtroppo se fuori escono fuori mi
fa quasi per chiedo sempre morire nord
est nord nono tentati dalle tue spaesato
e di chi lo sa e attenzione
e un'altra destra pure ti veloce eccolo
lì davanti a fare qua
antica neanche ma sai che non avevo
proprio visto ma è difficile che
permetta a vedere potete anche aspetti
ragazzi e la se ce l'avete molto vicina
potete ascoltare a sparare secondo me
bello bella pietra grande l'ora grazie
la grande valore vai grandissimi ragazzi
mancano otto persone ragazzi siete in
due lasciate che si sparino questi
guardate la prossima 6
michael a la vela ea sud ovest pietro a
sud ovest dietro di pose è un quell'alba
esatto ballo grandi perché se non di
carattere prossima safe è molto vicina
li vedono di lecce non sparare non spari
non ingaggiare dell'aspetto aspetti
aspettano non far vedere posizione
scendete sicuro
sono in tre a 100 120 poi cosa fai così
cimo l'albero quello sinistra loro
stanno viaggiando da barca di una vacca
infame laida
allora crea live
eccola a quando è calato un cecchino la
di youtube ha pushato contro una sorta
di folla correndo con zecchino ma
secondo te incazzato pietri secondo me è
un po arrabbiati non capisco se mi
chiedi blocchiamo se ps ti sei
arrabbiato
no dobbiamo stare vicini soldati
parlando il comandante veloci sì sì sì
esiste alcun alimento porca vacca sun
dalla stampa ecco le colpe giocatore ora
pistonina dirgli da una papera benissimo
e dentro langar ed entro l'anno broccato
parti loro parti far di libero di madre
ma anche da sinistra 20 secondi c'è un
investe per david esatto la partita ora
che ci siamo posti alle tastiere
vorrei che le voci di una barca
parcheggiata qua e là parcheggio sotto
sei un pazzo per i poteri per l'articolo
non è vero ci stanno sparando si citano
sparando entrate diventato l'hub occhio
uno sto sparando di qua lo vedo lo
ammazzo ti mostra su ok
questo caso attuale non solo sparando
disperato che rimane fermo se poi
campionato ma che parla di cosa parli
dietro muri fatti su tempo non lo vedo
anna era mantecato orco due terre caso
perché da quello che hai giocato con
campo restano in alto 62 46 più è
riferiti alle spalle ed ora ce n'è un
altro
mi spara ancora uno dopo l'altro non lo
so a nord ovest nord est est nord est
100 cv entato nord est fatta arrivare o
rimandato all'anno di morto ok non
l'avremo presente un'unità di quanta
gente ci può sembrare avanti a me pieno
ecco le 10 su 12 ai figli di papà cuore
sono in due che lascia quello lascia
quello a destra ma seguo ha detto o
quali si ebbero sinistra adesso mi
faccio ripensarlo spoiler e c'è una
granata bella e via città bellissima a
laureati prova guidare se pronto
insomma
morto ce n'è ancora c'è un altro gruppo
però no chao credito ma che va servito
sul compagno no demonio c'è al momento
troppo
quindi ragazzi questa era la erano le
sessioni di gioco le ultime sessioni di
gioco che abbiamo fatto probabilmente
adesso thomas e pietro con un canale e
fanno 8 milioni di iscritti
fabio capra anzi quindi spero che vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi cose e mi piace anche
vari social convinto descrizione sono
questi schiavi e non ci vediamo cosa
possiamo vino dai ragazzi come l'ho
preso male beh ragazzi oggi a santa
1.500 milioni sono ancora prenderebbe
nel telecomando come possibile
palombo
[Musica]